Shure: yes
Shure: Yes
Jake: 开始吧开始吧
Jake: Let's start, let's start
Shure:  能对一下那什么吗
Shure: Can you check that thing?
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm
Jake: 大家互相看一下谁的红灯
Jake: Everyone, look around and see whose red light is on
Jake: 白灯没有亮就是
Jake: If the white light is off, it means...
Lucia: 亮了吗
Lucia: Is it on?
Katrina: 亮了
Katrina: It's on
Shure: 都亮了
Shure: They're all on
Jake: 亮了很亮很亮
Jake: It's on, very bright, very bright
Jake: 来看一会
Jake: Come, take a look
Lucia: OK
Jake: 好看吗
Jake: Looks good?
Shure:  好看
Shure: Looks good
Shure:  太棒了
Shure: Awesome
Jake: 好看
Jake: Looks good
Alice: 好看
Alice: Looks good
Jake: 好看
Jake: Looks good
Shure:  来给AI喂点抖音
Shure: Let's feed the AI some TikTok
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Tasha: 自己想看
Tasha: Wants to watch it
Jake:评论评论评论
Jake: Comment, comment, comment
Jake: 这谁啊
Jake: Who is this?
Shure: 陈泽啊
Shure: It's Chen Ze
Katrina:  呵呵陈泽有点抽象真的
Katrina: Haha, Chen Ze is a bit abstract, really
Jake:说你整我呢
Jake: Says you're messing with me
Jake: 天天小考
Jake: Daily quizzes
Katrina:  哎呀
Katrina: Aiya
Jake:哎呦 卧槽
Jake: Oops, damn
Jake:沙雕
Jake: Silly
Shure: 成谢谢您
Shure: Alright, thank you
Jake: 好好嘞
Jake: Alright then
Jake: 哎呀
Jake: Oh dear
Shure:  掉出来了
Shure: It fell out
Jake: 哎呀怎么掉出来了
Jake: Oh no, how did it fall out?
Jake: 会是老板第一个下车
Jake: The boss will be the first to get off
Jake: 一般老板是第一个下车吗
Jake: Is the boss usually the first to get off?
Shure:  不知道
Shure: I don't know
Lucia: 不是应该先
Lucia: 司机先下车
Lucia: The driver gets off first
Lucia: 然后给你把门拉开这种
Lucia: And then I'll open the door for you.
Jake:一般老板应该 不会第一个下车
Jake: Usually, the boss wouldn't be the first to get out of the car.
Shure:  万一遇刺什么的是吧
Shure: In case of an assassination, right?
Jake: 对第一个下车第一个被崩
Jake: Yeah, the first to get out is the first to get shot.
Shure: 第一个下了之后喽
Shure: After getting out first...
Shure:  保镖
Shure: Bodyguards.
Jake: 怎么过去啊
Jake: How do we get across?
Jake: 怎么停在这么个地方啊
Jake: Why did we stop here?
Tasha: 跨过去
Tasha: Just step over it.
Shure: 我们只要
Shure: We just need to...
Jake: 你跨一下
Jake: Step over it.
Shure: 助跑一下
Shure: Get a running start.
Lucia: 助跑一下哈哈哈
Lucia: Get a running start, haha.
Shure:  迟到了
Shure: We're late.
Shure:  这怎么给停这地方
Shure: Why did we stop here?
Lucia: 我好像有一点点晕
Lucia: I feel a bit dizzy.
Shure:  给差评
Shure: Give a bad review.
Jake: 给差评
Jake: Give a bad review.
Jake: 咋整啊
Jake: What now?
Jake: 那边是可以走吗
Jake: Can we walk over there?
Jake:那那那过得去吗
Jake: Can we get through there?
Jake: 过不去
Jake: No, we can't.
Tasha: 盒马在哪
Tasha: Where's Hema?
Jake: 绕一圈吧
Jake: Let's go around.
Jake: 问问吧
Jake: Let's ask.
Shure: 盒马
Shure: Hema?
Lucia: 那个有点高吧感觉跨不过去啊
Lucia: That looks too high, I don't think we can step over it.
Shure:  师傅那个盒马鲜生在哪
Shure: Excuse me, where is Hema Fresh?
Shure:  从从这边绕过去是吗
Shure: We need to go around from here, right?
Shure:  好的
Shure: Got it.
Shure:  谢谢你
Shure: Thank you.
Jake: 这个行人还得这么绕
Jake: Pedestrians have to go all the way around.
Lucia: 哎不是
Lucia: Hey, wait.
Lucia: 等一下同志们
Lucia: Hold on, everyone.
Lucia: 腿长的人已经先过去了
Lucia: The long-legged people have already crossed.
Lucia: 呵呵是这是是是
Lucia: Haha, yes, that's right.
Jake:我靠
Jake: Oh my god.
Shure:  这这边绕一下吧
Shure: Let's go around this way.
Shure:  还是
Shure: Or...
Katrina: 这边过去
Katrina: Go this way.
Katrina:  在那边
Katrina: Over there.
Shure:  对走吧走吧
Shure: Yes, let's go, let's go.
Jake: 头盔要不给他吧
Jake: Should we give him the helmet?
Jake: 他跑过了
Jake: He ran past.
Lucia: 哈哈腿长的人已经先过去了
Lucia: Haha, the person with long legs already went ahead.
Jake: 跑过了他们
Jake: He ran past them.
Jake: 你也要去
Jake: Are you going too?
Lucia: 不行我今天穿这衣服我翻不了
Lucia: No, I can't climb in this outfit today.
Jake:你今天你今天不太行
Jake: You're not in good shape today.
Jake:下次一定
Jake: Next time for sure.
Shure:  外面大门没有门禁
Shure: The main gate outside doesn't have access control.
Jake:人呢
Jake: Where is everyone?
Jake: 补一个
Jake: Let's fix one.
Alice: 底下那个底掉了没法往上弄了
Alice: The bottom part fell off, can't put it back.
Tasha: 对啊
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake:就翻的时候掉了是吗
Jake: It fell off when you flipped it, right?
Jake:这唱的还挺好
Jake: This singing is pretty good.
Jake:来带大家看看这个
Jake: Come, let me show you this.
Jake:北京大超市
Jake: A big supermarket in Beijing.
Jake: 他们已经上去了
Jake: They've already gone up.
Tasha: 为什么不等我们
Tasha: Why didn't they wait for us?
Jake: 这么快的
Jake: So fast.
Jake:好惨呐
Jake: So miserable.
Jake: 他们是上去了
Jake: They went up.
Jake: 这怎么上来这么快啊
Jake: How did they get up so quickly?
Lucia: 什么情况
Lucia: What's going on?
Lucia: 你们怎么已经到了啊
Lucia: How did you guys get here so fast?
Jake: 我们还找你们呢
Jake: We were still looking for you.
Jake: 怎么丢了呀
Jake: How did we lose you?
Katrina:  系了个鞋带而已
Katrina: I was just tying my shoelaces.
Shure:  我们我们跟着轩导的步伐来着
Shure: We were following the guide's pace.
Jake: 哦对
Jake: Oh right.
Jake: 殊途同归
Jake: All roads lead to the same destination.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina:  柯达照相
Katrina: Kodak photo.
Shure:  我们之前去那nar的时候买了一次性的胶圈
Shure: When we went to that nar place, we bought a disposable ring.
Katrina:  哦我之前也想买
Katrina: Oh, I wanted to buy one too.
Tasha: 伤心
Tasha: So sad.
Katrina:  我以为我们宿舍毕业旅行会去就
Katrina: I thought our dorm graduation trip would be there.
Alice:买一套工具自己做
Alice: Buy a set of tools and do it yourself.
Katrina:  新疆那地方就打算买一个
Katrina: I plan to buy one in Xinjiang.
Tasha: 早知道不翻了
Tasha: If I knew earlier, I wouldn't have turned it over.
Alice: 这翻掉了
Alice: It flipped over.
Katrina:  我特别喜欢那种感觉那拍出来的
Katrina: I really like the feeling of those pictures.
Katrina:  那你有冲洗出来吗还是直打
Katrina: Did you develop them or just print directly?
Shure: 啊没没洗成那什么
Shure: Ah, I didn't manage to develop them.
Katrina: 就是导出电子版是吧
Katrina: So you just exported the digital version, right?
Shure: 对弄电子版然后再是胶片
Shure: Yes, export the digital version and then print on film.
Shure: 就是你透过阳光是能看到那个影子的
Shure: You can see the shadow through the sunlight.
Katrina:  好浪漫啊
Katrina: So romantic.
Shure: 是吧
Shure: Right?
Jake: 这是啥地方
Jake: Where is this?
Alice: 找到一双长睫毛的大眼睛哎
Alice: Found a pair of big eyes with long eyelashes.
Alice: 找到了在那
Alice: Found them, over there.
Shure:  哇
Shure: Wow.
Alice: 哎让ai来一下
Alice: Hey, let AI come over.
Lucia: 不好意思又踩到你了
Lucia: Sorry, I stepped on you again.
Katrina:  海澜之家
Katrina: HLA.
Katrina:  海澜之家就在我们家旁边
Katrina: HLA is right next to our house.
Shure: 海澜之家男人的衣柜
Shure: HLA, the wardrobe for men.
Jake: 这得多瞎啊
Jake: How blind must you be?
Jake: 他看不到啊
Jake: He can't see it.
Alice: 还有呢
Alice: What else?
Alice: 怎么有股有毒的味道
Alice: Why does it smell toxic?
Tasha: 用这个眼镜去测试你看
Tasha: Use these glasses to test, look.
Tasha: 做测试这
Tasha: Do the test here.
Lucia: 感觉刚装修完似得
Lucia: Feels like it's just been renovated.
Tasha: 在车站中找到海澜之家
Tasha: Found HLA at the station.
Alice: 哦原来在这等着我们呢
Alice: Oh, that's where they were waiting for us.
Alice: 软广
Alice: Product placement.
Tasha: 还真没找着
Tasha: I really didn't find it.
Jake: 怎么找啊
Jake: How do you find it?
Jake: 海澜之家是啥啊
Jake: What's HLA?
Alice:海澜之家
Alice: HLA.
Lucia: 就是一个卖男装的品牌
Lucia: It's a brand that sells men's clothing.
Jake:那他是什么找他的logo吗
Jake: So he's looking for their logo?
Jake: 他logo是什么样的
Jake: What's their logo like?
Alice: 有嘛区别呢
Alice: Does it make any difference?
Alice:让AI来找一下
Alice: Let AI find it.
Lucia: 怎么觉得没有都一样啊
Lucia: Why does it feel like they're all the same?
Jake:都不知道要找什么
Jake: I don't even know what to look for.
Tasha: 难度可能是进阶的
Tasha: Maybe it's at an advanced level.
Alice: 他可能就是
Alice: He might just...
Jake:他应该
Jake: He probably...
Alice: 为了给你留下一个深刻的印象
Alice: ...want to leave a deep impression on you.
Jake:可能他就没有
Jake: Maybe he just doesn't...
Tasha: 然后就一直在找海澜
Tasha: And then he keeps looking for Hailan.
Jake:对一个一个找
Jake: Yeah, one by one.
Alice: 然后你就特别特别想知道
Alice: Then you really, really want to know...
Alice: 海澜之家到底长啥样
Alice: ...what Hailan Home actually looks like.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Alice: 然后他的目的就达到了
Alice: Then his goal is achieved.
Alice:是这样吗
Alice: Is that right?
Jake: 所以应该长啥样
Jake: So, what should it look like?
Alice: 我也不知道
Alice: I don't know either.
Jake: 海澜之家是自己有个logo是长这样吗
Jake: Does Hailan Home have its own logo like this?
Katrina: 海澜的马场
Katrina: Hailan's ranch.
Jake: 还是啥呀
Jake: Or what?
Alice: 海澜之家
Alice: Hailan Home.
Alice: 我就记得一个h一个l他们家的门面
Alice: I just remember an H and an L, their storefront.
Jake:他logo长啥样不知道哇
Jake: You don't know what their logo looks like?
Lucia: 啊好像是
Lucia: Ah, I think so.
Lucia: 不了解因为因为咱们平常也不买男装
Lucia: Not sure, because we usually don't buy men's clothes.
Alice: 我感觉里面就是没有我感觉都一样
Alice: I feel like inside, everything looks the same.
Jake: 对我也不买男装
Jake: Yeah, I don't buy men's clothes either.
Tasha: 那他穿什么
Tasha: Then what does he wear?
Alice:怪怪的
Alice: That's weird.
Jake: 就这个哈哈哈哈
Jake: Just this, hahaha.
Tasha: 你看喜茶标志很明显
Tasha: Look, the HeyTea logo is very obvious.
Jake: 这个确实哎
Jake: Yeah, that's true.
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Right.
Lucia: 那可能是上面确实有个标志只是没找到
Lucia: Maybe there's a logo up there, we just didn't find it.
Tasha: 还测吗哈哈
Tasha: Are we still testing? Haha.
Alice: 这有一股有毒的味道
Alice: It smells kind of toxic here.
Alice: 感觉在这闻久了要晕倒
Alice: I feel like I'll faint if I stay here long enough.
Lucia:有种没装修完的
Lucia: Feels like it's not fully renovated.
Tasha: 是两位男生推购物车吗
Tasha: Are the two guys pushing shopping carts?
Jake:行啊
Jake: Sure.
Tasha: 推两辆是吗
Tasha: Pushing two carts?
Jake: 行啊没问题
Jake: Sure, no problem.
Tasha: 一一边采购酒一边采购食材是吗
Tasha: Are we buying both the alcohol and the groceries at the same time?
Jake: 呃啊酒要单独一个车吧
Jake: Uh, the alcohol should probably have its own cart.
Jake: 推个小的
Jake: Push a small one.
Lucia: 还有小的
Lucia: There's a small one too.
Lucia: 啊太小了推起来不好推
Lucia: Ah, it's too small to push comfortably.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 有那个小把手
Tasha: It has a small handle.
Lucia: 这就是小孩推的意思吗
Lucia: Is it meant for kids to push?
Jake: 哦是
Jake: Oh, yes.
Lucia: 是把小孩放在里面推小孩的意思吗
Lucia: Is it for putting kids inside and pushing them around?
Tasha: 是让小孩推这个车的意思
Tasha: It's for kids to push.
Alice:是让小孩推得
Alice: It's for kids to push.
Jake: 小孩应该也进不去
Jake: Kids probably can't fit in there.
Jake: 这得是
Jake: It has to be...
Jake:猫
Jake: Cats.
Lucia: 不会是把小孩放在里面
Lucia: You don't put kids in there.
Tasha: 这这小孩坐这
Tasha: Kids sit here.
Jake: 请
Jake: Please.
Tasha: 谁
Tasha: Who?
Alice:请
Alice: Please.
Tasha: 谁
Tasha: Who?
Jake: 都行啊
Jake: Anyone.
Shure:  我能上吗
Shure: Can I get on?
Jake: 来
Jake: Come on.
Jake: 给你推货
Jake: I'll push your stuff.
Jake: 给你推冰柜去
Jake: I'll push your freezer.
Jake: 就那个水产
Jake: The seafood one.
Tasha: 买二得三
Tasha: Buy two get three.
Alice: 榴莲怎么这么便宜
Alice: Why is durian so cheap?
Tasha: 有人不爱吃榴莲吗
Tasha: Does anyone not like durian?
Jake: 我可以吃
Jake: I can eat it.
Lucia: 不是很爱
Lucia: Not a big fan.
Jake:走吧
Jake: Let's go.
Shure:  怎么说咱们是分头行动
Shure: So, are we splitting up?
Shure:  还是一起行动
Shure: Or are we sticking together?
Shure:  你把那个图po到那里吧
Shure: You should upload the map there.
Jake: 我们有分工吗
Jake: Do we have assigned tasks?
Jake: 我们分几个路啊
Jake: How many routes are we taking?
Alice: 分几个路啊
Alice: How many routes are we taking?
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: I don't know.
Jake: 其实我们戴着这个眼镜
Jake: Actually, with these glasses on,
Jake: 绕着一圈就重建了
Jake: walking around once, it gets reconstructed.
Jake: 就是这个整个商场商场就3D重建了
Jake: The whole mall gets 3D reconstructed.
Tasha: 场景
Tasha: The scene.
Jake: 就一个赛博盒马
Jake: It's like a cyber Hema store.
Shure: 所以那天
Shure: So that day,
Shure:  让我哈哈哈
Shure: made me laugh.
Jake: 每个角落走一圈
Jake: Walk around every corner.
Katrina: 我发了
Katrina: I sent it.
Katrina:  分其实5-10就是你们买菜啊
Katrina: Divide actually 5-10, like you guys shopping for groceries.
Katrina:  生活用品的那种地方
Katrina: Places for daily necessities.
Katrina:  可以你们那就分两拨
Katrina: You can divide into two groups.
Jake: 分两拨分两拨
Jake: Divide into two groups, divide into two groups.
Katrina: 分两拨
Katrina: Divide into two groups.
Tasha:  5-11
Tasha: 5-11.
Katrina:  5-11跟1-4
Katrina: 5-11 and 1-4.
Tasha: 你是1-4和12对吗
Tasha: You are 1-4 and 12, right?
Katrina:  啊可以可以
Katrina: Ah, okay, okay.
Lucia: 行
Lucia: Sure.
Katrina:  走我俩去哪个
Katrina: Where are we going?
Jake: 这是什么
Jake: What's this?
Jake: 这是这是什么组
Jake: What group is this?
Jake: 这是什么组 食材组
Jake: What group is this? The ingredients group.
Tasha: 这是食材组
Tasha: This is the ingredients group.
Tasha: 这是酒组
Jake: 酒组行行好
Jake: The drinks group, come on.
Katrina:  那你们还要一个过来不
Katrina: Do you still need one more person?
Katrina:  12123456 我俩再加一个
Katrina: 12123456, we can add one more.
Lucia: 33好了那就
Lucia: 33, okay then.
Katrina:  33
Katrina: 33.
Lucia: 行
Lucia: Sure.
Katrina: 他肯定要
Katrina: He definitely wants to.
Jake: 行那怎么说
Jake: Okay, what do you say?
Jake:对食材
Jake: Yes, the ingredients.
Katrina:  他是你们的主主星
Katrina: He is your main star.
Katrina:  组合里你俩选
Katrina: In the group, you two choose.
Alice: 我我我跟他绑定
Alice: Me, me, me, I'll pair with him.
Lucia: 我都都行
Lucia: I'm fine with anything.
Lucia: 那我来好了
Lucia: Then I'll do it.
Tasha: 嘿嘿嘿嘿好
Tasha: Hehe, okay.
Katrina:  那我们去买酒吧
Katrina: Then let's go buy some alcohol.
Tasha: 对你们三个都是懂酒的
Tasha: Right, you three know about drinks.
Lucia: 也没有那么
Lucia: Not really.
Lucia: 我我我没有那么懂了其实
Lucia: I... I don't know that much, actually.
Jake: 确实我是一点都不懂
Jake: Honestly, I don't know anything about it.
Jake: 我咖啡都不喝
Jake: I don't even drink coffee.
Katrina:  朗姆
Katrina: Rum.
Jake: 都没法买啥也没法
Jake: Can't buy anything, don't know anything.
Jake: 但是好像食品我也不懂
Jake: But it seems I don't know much about food either.
Lucia: 我可以申请买个水果
Lucia: Can I suggest buying some fruit?
Tasha: 买
Tasha: Sure.
Tasha: 想吃什么你可以跟我说啊
Tasha: Tell me if you want to eat anything specific.
Lucia: 随便只要是个水果就行
Lucia: Anything, just some fruit.
Katrina:  我想要那个青提
Katrina: I want those green grapes.
Jake:你也可以
Jake: You can too.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈真的
Lucia: Hahaha, really.
Katrina:  我要那个青提
Katrina: I want those green grapes.
Katrina:  阳光玫瑰那种
Katrina: The Shine Muscat ones.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Lucia: 好那我那我也吃这个就可以了
Lucia: Fine, I'll eat those too then.
Tasha: 啊好
Tasha: Alright.
Tasha: 啊这个会买的
Tasha: We'll buy those.
Tasha: 您觉得买一盒还是买两盒呢
Tasha: Do you think we should buy one box or two?
Jake: 买买哎我看看啊
Jake: Buy, buy... let me see.
Tasha: 我觉得可以买两盒
Tasha: I think we can buy two.
Tasha: 一盒做蛋糕一盒也吃
Tasha: One for making a cake and one to eat.
Jake:行
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 是不是买两盒
Jake: Should we buy two boxes?
Jake: 两盒都吃了呀
Jake: We'll eat both?
Alice:这个吧
Alice: This one.
Alice: 这个大
Alice: This one's big.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Jake: 你们可以商量商量
Jake: You guys can discuss it.
Jake: 为什么选这个
Jake: Why choose this one?
Tasha: 这个草莓好吃
Tasha: This strawberry is delicious.
Jake: 不是就是为什么这个
Jake: No, I mean why this one?
Alice: 因为这个有白的感觉没有很
Alice: Because this one feels white, not very...
Tasha: 他这个要买
Tasha: He wants to buy this.
Alice:饱满成熟
Alice: Full and ripe.
Tasha: 你看他这个虽然小但他多
Tasha: Look, even though this one is small, there are many of them.
Tasha: 这个虽然大但他少
Tasha: This one is big but there are fewer.
Alice: 他多吗
Alice: Are there many?
Tasha: 对对这个是多两排这个是少两排的
Tasha: Yeah, this one has two more rows, this one has two fewer rows.
Tasha: 我经常吃
Tasha: I eat it often.
Tasha: 对，他少两排
Tasha: Yeah, it has two fewer rows.
Alice:啊没发现
Alice: Ah, I didn't notice.
Tasha: 他少两排
Tasha: It has two fewer rows.
Tasha: 你看你没事
Tasha: You see, it's no big deal.
Alice:诶一排还是两排啊
Alice: Hey, is it one row or two rows?
Jake: 他这个他这个挡着
Jake: This one, this one is blocking.
Jake: 是有还是没有啊
Jake: Is it there or not?
Tasha: 呃有
Tasha: Uh, it's there.
Alice: 哦这是5排这是6排
Alice: Oh, this one has 5 rows, this one has 6 rows.
Tasha: 呃就是一排两排
Tasha: Uh, it's one row or two rows.
Jake:哦没那么狗是吧
Jake: Oh, it's not that bad, right?
Tasha: 这是一排两排三排四排对对
Tasha: This is one row, two rows, three rows, four rows, right, right.
Lucia: 要不问问他们
Lucia: Why not ask them?
Alice: 哦嗯那么要大的还是要小的呢
Alice: Oh, hmm, so should we get the big one or the small one?
Tasha: 那肯定要大的
Tasha: Definitely the big one.
Tasha: 这就是他们刚刚点名的
Tasha: This is the one they just mentioned.
Alice: 找一个果形饱满的
Alice: Find one that's full and plump.
Tasha: 我觉得这个比较多
Tasha: I think this one has more.
Alice: 都500克吧
Alice: They're all 500 grams, right?
Tasha: 但好像都是500克
Tasha: But it seems like they're all 500 grams.
Tasha: 那我选他吧
Tasha: Then I'll choose this one.
Tasha: 你觉得呢
Tasha: What do you think?
Tasha: 你有没有心仪的
Tasha: Do you have a favorite?
Alice: 我觉得长得都差不多
Alice: I think they all look about the same.
Tasha: 那这个吧
Tasha: Then this one.
Alice: 他们家评论还可以
Alice: Their reviews are pretty good.
Jake: 我看看这都多少钱
Jake: Let me see how much these are.
Tasha: 不能吃现切的
Tasha: You can't eat the freshly cut ones.
Jake: 我看看都多少钱
Jake: Let me see how much they are.
Jake: 我就看一眼
Jake: I'll just take a look.
Jake: 多少钱我比比价
Jake: How much are they, I'll compare prices.
Jake: 为什么不能吃现切的
Jake: Why can't you eat the freshly cut ones?
Tasha: 因为你没听过前段时间现切的事吗
Tasha: Because haven't you heard about the fresh cut ones recently?
Tasha: 把坏的切掉把好的然后
Tasha: Cut off the bad parts and keep the good ones.
Jake: 好的就在这卖了
Jake: We'll sell the good ones here.
Jake: 坏的就在这卖了
Jake: And sell the bad ones here.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Right.
Jake: 给世界人民涨涨知识
Jake: Let's educate the people of the world.
Tasha: 还有什么让我们看一看
Tasha: What else? Let's have a look.
Tasha: 水果采购
Tasha: Fruit shopping.
Tasha: 蓝莓要吗
Tasha: Do you want blueberries?
Jake:蓝莓可以要
Jake: We can get blueberries.
Alice: 需要凤梨吗
Alice: Do we need pineapple?
Shure: 就跟这个一个大瓶
Shure: Just like this one big bottle.
Tasha: 你喜欢吃可以拿一盒
Tasha: If you like it, you can get a box.
Alice:我觉得一般
Alice: I think it's just okay.
Lucia: 哦那种小小的
Lucia: Oh, those small ones.
Tasha: 我也觉得一般
Tasha: I think it's just okay too.
Lucia: 对但是那种太小了
Lucia: Yeah, but those are too small.
Tasha: 这个也可以用来摆
Tasha: This can also be used for display.
Alice: 再加一个黄的
Alice: Add one more yellow one.
Tasha: 黄的芒果
Tasha: A yellow mango.
Alice:芒果
Alice: Mango.
Jake:菠萝
Jake: Pineapple.
Alice: 芒果
Alice: Mango.
Tasha: 菠萝不太好放在甜品里
Tasha: Pineapple isn't good for desserts.
Jake: 甜品来尝尝
Jake: Try the dessert.
Alice: 买这个吧
Alice: Let's buy this.
Alice:这个他们家的
Alice: This one, from their store.
Alice:那种
Alice: That kind.
Alice: 那种叫什么来着
Alice: What's it called again?
Jake: 不是不能现切吗
Jake: Can't we cut it fresh?
Jake: 到底能不能现切
Jake: Can we cut it fresh or not?
Tasha: 其实我觉得现切的不太好
Tasha: Actually, I think fresh cut isn't very good.
Tasha: 你可以买那个让他帮你现场切
Tasha: You can buy it and have them cut it on the spot for you.
Jake: 那可以啊
Jake: That works.
Jake: 但是买凤梨不是不是
Jake: But if we buy pineapple, should we...
Jake:放不放甜点里
Jake: Should we put it in the dessert?
Tasha: 不放
Tasha: No.
Jake: 啊就自己吃
Jake: Oh, just eat it ourselves.
Jake:好让他切吧
Jake: Alright, let them cut it.
Jake: 给他拍一个特写一个切的
Jake: Take a close-up shot of him cutting it.
Tasha: 你看他可以呼叫店员帮你切
Tasha: You see, you can call the staff to help you cut it.
Jake: 好切
Jake: Alright, cut it.
Tasha: 挑的话挑那种刺比较尖的
Tasha: If you're picking, choose the one with sharper thorns.
Jake: 挑比较大格子比较大
Jake: Pick the one with bigger grids.
Jake: 这个我会
Jake: I can do this.
Jake: 这个我在新加坡
Jake: I did this in Singapore.
Jake: 这个我在新加坡切过
Jake: I cut this in Singapore.
Tasha: 你觉得这两个哪个好
Tasha: Which one do you think is better?
Jake:这个我看看
Jake: Let me have a look.
Alice:还有点扎呢
Alice: It's still a bit prickly.
Alice:这个是不是更熟
Alice: Is this one more ripe?
Jake:这个吧
Jake: This one.
Alice:我也不知道
Alice: I don't know either.
Alice: 绿不拉几差不多吧
Alice: It's pretty green, isn't it?
Alice: 差不多这个吧
Alice: Maybe this one.
Jake: 看谁胖一点哇
Jake: Let's see who's fatter.
Jake:这个吧就这个吧
Jake: This one, let's go with this one.
Alice: 您好
Alice: Hello.
Jake: 您好
Jake: Hello.
Jake: 切，谢谢您
Jake: Cut it, thank you.
Jake: 这就下班了
Jake: Done for the day.
Jake: 这才几点
Jake: What time is it?
Jake: 那我们现在谁跟我说来着
Jake: Who was talking to me just now?
Tasha: 那他什么时候开始切
Tasha: When will he start cutting?
Tasha: 行吧那我们买个这个吧
Tasha: Alright, let's buy this one.
Jake:行吧
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 你挑一个
Tasha: You pick one.
Jake: 行吧那就大家信他一回
Jake: Alright, let's trust him this time.
Tasha: 买一个这个才8块钱
Tasha: Buying this one only costs 8 yuan.
Tasha: 我觉得小台芒是芒果里面最甜的
Tasha: I think mini Thai mangoes are the sweetest.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 你挑挑哪个
Tasha: You pick one.
Tasha: 是6个的啊
Tasha: Is it the one with 6?
Tasha: 我刚看到这个是6个但他这有霉点
Tasha: I just saw this one has 6, but it has mold spots.
Tasha: 所以要挑一个另一个6个的
Tasha: So, pick another one with 6.
Alice:小台芒的吗
Alice: The mini Thai mangoes?
Tasha: 发挥你的眼睛对
Tasha: Use your eyes, yes.
Alice: 小台芒比较甜比较软
Alice: Mini Thai mangoes are sweeter and softer.
Tasha: 对小台芒
Tasha: Yes, mini Thai mangoes.
Jake:这是6个吗
Jake: Are there 6?
Tasha: OK看看水果就买齐了吧
Tasha: OK, let's see if we have all the fruits now.
Tasha: 下一步是
Tasha: The next step is
Tasha: 牛奶无菌蛋牛奶
Tasha: Milk, pasteurized egg milk
Alice:这是你外送的
Alice: This is your delivery
Jake: 对我在拍他
Jake: Yep, I'm filming him
Jake: 给个特写
Jake: Give a close-up
Alice:这款还挺好喝的
Alice: This one's pretty good
Tasha: 我我也觉着
Tasha: I, I think so too
Tasha: 椰子水拿一瓶吧
Tasha: Let's grab a bottle of coconut water
Tasha: 但在哪呢
Tasha: But where is it?
Alice:椰子水买那个吧
Alice: Let's buy that coconut water
Tasha: 这个哎这个
Tasha: This one, hey this one
Tasha: 这个贵了一点
Tasha: This one's a bit expensive
Alice: 这个就是那个便宜的
Alice: This one is the cheaper one
Tasha: 这个是便
Tasha: This is chea...
Tasha: 是便宜的啊
Tasha: Oh, it's cheap
Tasha: 他们都是一升
Tasha: They're all one liter
Alice: 这怎么是8块9了
Alice: How is this 8.9 yuan?
Tasha: 对他们都是一升
Tasha: Yeah, they're all one liter
Tasha: 但他只要8块9
Tasha: But this one is only 8.9 yuan
Lucia: 我猜的
Lucia: I'm just guessing
Alice: 果汁哦
Alice: Juice, oh
Alice: 果汁是他们买
Alice: They bought the juice
Tasha: 还有东西吗
Tasha: Anything else?
Tasha: 牛奶无菌蛋
Tasha: Milk, pasteurized eggs
Alice: 牛奶买了吗
Alice: Did you buy the milk?
Tasha: 牛奶买了
Tasha: Yeah, bought the milk
Alice: 两盒够不够
Alice: Are two cartons enough?
Tasha: 够了吧
Tasha: Should be enough
Alice:无菌蛋
Alice: Pasteurized eggs
Tasha: 鸡蛋鸡蛋
Tasha: Eggs, eggs
Jake:淡奶油在什么地方
Jake: Where's the heavy cream?
Tasha: 淡奶油在
Tasha: Heavy cream is...
Jake:在很里边吗
Jake: Is it deep inside?
Alice: 奶油应该在酸奶这边
Alice: The cream should be near the yogurt
Alice: 是差不多的地吧
Alice: It's around the same area
Tasha: 我觉得差不多在冰柜这里
Tasha: I think it's probably in the freezer section
Jake: 要不问问他嘞
Jake: How about we ask him?
Jake: 你这有淡奶油卖吗
Jake: Do you sell heavy cream here?
Jake: 您家哦还不是一家
Jake: Is it your store? Oh, not your store
Jake: 哈喽
Jake: Hello
Lucia:  哈喽
Lucia: Hello
Shure:  你平时喝酒吗
Shure: Do you usually drink alcohol?
Lucia: 你问我们俩的谁
Lucia: Who are you asking, the two of us?
Lucia: 里面的谁
Lucia: Which one of us?
Shure: 你们俩
Shure: Both of you
Jake: 我来瞅瞅你们买的啥
Jake: Let me see what you guys bought
Jake: 你们看起来进度一般了
Jake: You guys seem to be making average progress
Katrina:  嗯没找到饮料
Katrina: Yeah, we couldn't find the drinks
Shure:  是要我们大买特买那个意思吗
Shure: Are you saying we should buy a lot?
Lucia: 他买了椰子水
Lucia: He bought coconut water
Lucia: 刚好我们不用买了啊
Lucia: So we don't need to buy any
Katrina:  哦他们买了椰子水
Katrina: Oh, they bought coconut water
Katrina:  是要用椰奶还是椰子水啊
Katrina: Do we need coconut milk or coconut water?
Lucia: 呃其实最好是椰奶
Lucia: Uh, actually, coconut milk would be better
Lucia: 但是咱们也没有那么那个啥嘛
Lucia: But we don't really have that
Shure:  椰奶和椰子水完全两个味啊
Shure: Coconut milk and coconut water taste completely different
Tasha: 我暂时还不在你
Tasha: I'm not with you right now
Tasha: 要不明天再
Tasha: How about tomorrow?
Tasha: 我明天再去拿行吗
Tasha: Can I go get it tomorrow?
Tasha: 好谢谢
Tasha: Okay, thank you
Alice: 买两个
Alice: Buy two
Tasha: 你看网上才卖12块五
Tasha: Look, it's only 12.50 online
Tasha: 是这个
Tasha: This one
Jake:淡奶油找着了吗
Jake: Did you find the whipping cream?
Tasha: 好吧它是安佳
Tasha: Okay, it's Anchor
Jake:就这个
Jake: This one
Tasha: 它是雀巢
Tasha: It's Nestlé
Alice: 安佳会比较贵
Alice: Anchor is more expensive
Tasha: 贵了10块钱一瓶
Tasha: It's 10 yuan more per bottle
Jake:淡奶油他在一伙那 我们觉得这不够
Jake: The whipping cream is with the group, we think it's not enough
Jake: 太少了还有多的吧
Jake: It's too little, is there more?
Jake: 这种类太少了
Jake: This kind is too little
Jake:那行吧谢谢您
Jake: Alright, thanks
Jake: 这还能小时达吗还是明天达
Jake: Can this be delivered within the hour or by tomorrow?
Tasha: 是啊我要看看嘛
Tasha: Yeah, let me check
Jake:你这可以选的诶
Jake: You can choose this
Tasha: 一件
Tasha: Just one
Jake: 我帮你拿
Jake: I'll help you carry it
Jake: 不用谢
Jake: No problem
Alice: 这好可爱这是什么
Alice: This is so cute, what is it?
Lucia: 如果少了可能还要再买
Lucia: If it's not enough, we might need to buy more.
Jake: 那就网上买
Jake: Then just buy it online.
Lucia: 可能吧
Lucia: Maybe.
Jake:行啊可以网上下个单呗
Jake: Sure, we can place an order online.
Jake: 不要紧啊
Jake: No problem.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Jake:然后下单
Jake: Then place an order.
Lucia: 如果22号的那天的话可以先在网上买
Lucia: If it's on the 22nd, we can buy it online first.
Jake:22号那一天
Jake: On the 22nd.
Tasha: 不是说那天要做蛋糕吗
Tasha: Didn't you say we were going to bake a cake that day?
Tasha: 谢谢
Tasha: Thanks.
Jake: 厉害你这个
Jake: You're amazing.
Jake: 这戴个帽子就把头发挡住了
Jake: Just put on a hat and it hides your hair.
Tasha: 然后要什么来着
Tasha: What else do we need?
Alice: 对无菌蛋
Alice: Sterilized eggs.
Tasha: 鸡蛋
Tasha: Eggs.
Tasha: 糖盐
Tasha: Sugar and salt.
Tasha: 奶粉咖啡冻奶油薄荷保鲜膜
Tasha: Milk powder, coffee, whipped cream, mint, cling film.
Tasha: 蛋挞皮草莓
Tasha: Tart crusts, strawberries.
Tasha: 美文纸为什么也是我们买
Tasha: Why do we have to buy the paper too?
Tasha: 金针菇3-4个
Tasha: 3-4 enoki mushrooms.
Tasha: 松花蛋娃娃菜
Tasha: Century eggs, baby bok choy.
Tasha: 记住了吗
Tasha: Got it?
Tasha: 走吧
Tasha: Let's go.
Jake: 娃娃菜走
Jake: Baby bok choy, let's go.
Tasha: 诶鸡蛋
Tasha: Hey, eggs.
Tasha: 买鸡蛋送松花蛋
Tasha: Buy eggs and get century eggs for free.
Tasha: 刚好哎
Tasha: Perfect.
Jake: 诶刚好啊
Jake: Perfect timing.
Alice: 鲜鸡蛋吧
Alice: Fresh eggs?
Tasha: 啊鲜鸡蛋也可以吧
Tasha: Yeah, fresh eggs are fine too.
Jake: 你们家离高邮远吗
Jake: Is your home far from Gaoyou?
Jake: 高邮
Jake: Gaoyou.
Jake: 啊你们家离那远
Jake: Is your home far from there?
Alice: 高邮鸭蛋哦
Alice: Gaoyou salted duck eggs.
Alice: 咸鸭蛋
Alice: Salted duck eggs.
Tasha: 不远
Tasha: Not far.
Tasha: 你们家也不远啊
Tasha: Your home isn't far either.
Jake:啊对确实
Jake: Yeah, that's true.
Alice: 哦那个是可生食的哦
Alice: Oh, that one can be eaten raw.
Tasha: 这呢我觉得可生食的买一点就行了
Tasha: I think it's enough to buy a little of the edible one.
Tasha: 然后再买一盒这个也可以了
Tasha: And then we can buy a box of this too.
Alice: 行啊
Alice: Sure.
Tasha: 这个就买
Tasha: Let's buy this.
Tasha: 呃做那个提拉米苏
Tasha: Uh, to make Tiramisu.
Alice:提拉米苏用
Alice: For the Tiramisu?
Tasha: 对然后别的都可以用
Tasha: Yes, and everything else can be used.
Tasha: 用非无菌的蛋
Tasha: Use non-sterilized eggs.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Alice: 熟的就行
Alice: Cooked ones are fine.
Jake: 无菌蛋无菌蛋是什么意思
Jake: What's a sterilized egg?
Tasha: 无菌蛋就是你现在直接可以吃下去
Tasha: A sterilized egg is one you can eat right away.
Jake: 就是他为什么叫无菌蛋
Jake: Why is it called a sterilized egg?
Tasha: 因为有
Tasha: Because it...
Tasha: 因为他就是不会有细菌吧
Tasha: It probably doesn't have bacteria.
Tasha: 可能
Tasha: Maybe.
Alice:是什么沙门氏菌什么的
Alice: Like Salmonella or something.
Jake: 他就是这个鸡比较牛逼
Jake: Is it because the chicken is amazing?
Jake: 还是
Jake: Or...
Alice: 就是他的那个饲养流程比较那啥
Alice: It's probably because of the strict feeding process.
Alice: 控制比较严
Alice: Strict control.
Jake: 刚生下来然后就被保存起来了之类的
Jake: As soon as they're born, they're preserved or something.
Alice: 具体的不是很清楚
Alice: I'm not very sure about the details.
Jake: OK OK行
Jake: OK, OK, got it.
Tasha: 无菌蛋牛奶白糖盐
Tasha: Sterilized eggs, milk, sugar, salt.
Alice: 调味料那边
Alice: Over there with the seasonings.
Alice: 哦那边是蔬菜
Alice: Oh, the vegetables are over there.
Alice: 买点菌菇类的
Alice: Let's buy some mushrooms.
Jake: 买 买
Jake: Buy, buy.
Alice: 为什么娃娃菜这么贵
Alice: Why is napa cabbage so expensive?
Jake:你要买吗
Jake: Do you want to buy it?
Jake:高山鲜
Jake: It's fresh from the mountains.
Alice: 没有普通的吗
Alice: Don't they have regular ones?
Jake:没有
Jake: No.
Tasha: 老板你有想吃的吗
Tasha: Boss, do you have anything you want to eat?
Alice: 这是大白菜啊
Alice: This is napa cabbage, right?
Jake:我把我想吃的人都招过来了 会做吗
Jake: I gathered everyone I wanted to eat with. Can you cook it?
Tasha: 就买这个娃娃菜买了吗
Tasha: Did you buy the napa cabbage?
Jake:会做好吃的菜的人都招过来了  没有没有
Jake: I gathered people who can cook well. No, no.
Jake: 这玩意他买了吗
Jake: Did he buy this thing?
Alice: 没有但是我感觉好贵啊他
Alice: No, but I feel like it's so expensive.
Tasha: 但是看着也挺好嫩的怎么这么贵去我家地里摘吧
Tasha: But it looks pretty fresh, why is it so expensive? Let's just pick some from my garden.
Alice: 主要是他一煮他就很小啦
Alice: The main thing is, once you cook it, it shrinks a lot.
Tasha: 那拿点上海青
Tasha: Then get some Shanghai Bok Choy.
Tasha: 上海青才一块钱哈哈
Tasha: Shanghai Bok Choy is just one yuan, haha.
Alice: 但是他没那个味
Alice: But it doesn't have that flavor.
Alice: 让我找一下
Alice: Let me look for it.
Alice: 要不然买成这个
Alice: Or we could buy this.
Alice: 我们我们可以我们把帮
Alice: We, we can, we can help...
Jake: 为什么这个不行
Jake: Why can't we use this?
Alice: 因为那个比较贵
Alice: Because that one is more expensive.
Jake:他为什么贵啊
Jake: Why is it expensive?
Jake: 这个多少钱
Jake: How much is this?
Alice: 白菜能贵到哪
Alice: How expensive can cabbage be?
Alice: 一千 1千克的话
Alice: One kilogram is...
Alice:白菜
Alice: Cabbage.
Tasha: 没有价格怎么回事
Tasha: Why is there no price tag?
Alice:这是杭白菜吗
Alice: Is this Hangzhou Bok Choy?
Tasha: 你去那扫个码就知道了
Tasha: Just scan the code over there and you'll know.
Alice: 这个5块钱哎
Alice: This is 5 yuan.
Jake: 那个十一块是吧
Jake: That one is 11 yuan, right?
Alice: 那个十一
Alice: That one is 11.
Alice: 并且两份也不太够
Alice: And even two portions aren't enough.
Alice: 买个这个
Alice: Let's buy this one.
Jake: 买鸡蛋了
Jake: Did we buy eggs?
Jake: 买了无菌蛋
Jake: We bought sterilized eggs.
Shure:  我们买了两个火锅底料
Shure: We bought two hot pot soup bases.
Jake: 火锅底料
Jake: Hot pot soup base.
Katrina: 没有桃汁啊
Katrina: There's no peach juice?
Jake: 我们好像我们我们分到了个
Jake: It seems like we got assigned some...
Jake: 什么奇怪的任务来着
Jake: Weird task.
Alice: 什么
Alice: What?
Jake:就和吃的没关系美纹纸美纹纸是什么东西
Jake: Something unrelated to food. What's masking tape?
Alice: 美纹纸
Alice: Masking tape?
Alice:美纹纸这有吗
Alice: Do they have masking tape here?
Katrina:  美文纸美文纸
Katrina: Masking tape, masking tape.
Lucia:美纹纸这这里面能买到吗
Lucia: Can we buy masking tape here?
Jake: 美纹纸是什么东西
Jake: What is masking tape?
Katrina: 就贴墙上不留痕的那贴纸
Katrina: It's the tape you stick on walls that doesn't leave a mark.
Katrina: 要不直接上网买吧
Katrina: How about we just buy it online?
Alice:再买两个
Alice: Let's buy two more.
Katrina: 跟那海报一起嘛嗯
Katrina: Together with that poster, right?
Katrina:  跟那个美纹纸很便宜
Katrina: And that masking tape is pretty cheap.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 嗯啊我觉得文具店也会有
Tasha: Hmm, I think the stationery store might have it too.
Katrina: 冰块模具还没买
Katrina: We haven't bought the ice cube mold yet.
Katrina: 盒马是不是主营饮食啊
Katrina: Is Hema mainly for food and drinks?
Alice:要不然我们买大白菜吧
Alice: Or we could buy napa cabbage.
Jake:跳舞了
Jake: Time to dance.
Jake:踩人舞
Jake: Step dance.
Alice:槐花你吃过吗
Alice: Have you ever eaten locust flower?
Tasha: 吃春菜
Tasha: Eating spring vegetables.
Katrina: 直接买柠檬也行
Katrina: We could just buy lemons.
Alice: 对槐花你吃过吗
Alice: Yeah, have you tried locust flower?
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: No.
Alice: 这可以炒可以做包子
Alice: You can stir-fry it or make buns with it.
Alice:很好吃甜甜的
Alice: It's really tasty, sweet.
Jake:啥意思啊
Jake: What do you mean?
Jake:我研究研究
Jake: I'll look into it.
Alice:就是这个是一种可以吃的东西
Alice: It's something you can eat.
Tasha: 金针菇买了吗
Tasha: Did you buy enoki mushrooms?
Alice: 买了买了
Alice: Got them, got them.
Jake:这为什么撒了呀
Jake: Why did it spill?
Alice:从缝里掉出来了
Alice: It fell through the crack.
Tasha: 那你吃啊快别浪费
Tasha: Then eat it quickly, don't waste it.
Alice:不是这不能生吃
Alice: No, you can't eat it raw.
Jake:哈哈哈下毒
Jake: Haha, poisoning.
Alice: 没事不要告诉他
Alice: It's fine, don't tell him.
Alice: 让他吃也行
Alice: Let him eat it.
Jake:那他吃了会怎么样呢
Jake: What will happen if he eats it?
Alice: 不好吃
Alice: It won't taste good.
Jake:主要是不好吃是吧
Jake: The main thing is it won't taste good, right?
Katrina: 青柠更适合还是柠檬更适合
Katrina: Is lime better or lemon better?
Tasha: 调味料还有胡椒粉味精盐
Tasha: Seasonings, we have pepper, MSG, and salt.
Shure: 都来
Shure: Get them all.
Alice:盐
Alice: Salt.
Tasha: 还有盐哎
Tasha: We also have salt.
Alice:嗯得找一个专门那啥的
Alice: Yeah, we need to find a specific one.
Jake:槐花呀
Jake: Locust flower, huh?
Alice:你吃过吗
Alice: Have you tried it before?
Tasha: 豆芽豆芽可以加进去吗
Tasha: Can we add bean sprouts?
Jake:我感觉还真吃过
Jake: I think I have tried it.
Alice:豆芽不可以没啥味
Alice: Bean sprouts don’t have much flavor.
Tasha: gogogo
Tasha: Go, go, go!
Jake:葱姜蒜有吗
Jake: Do we have scallions, ginger, and garlic?
Alice:葱姜蒜
Alice: Scallions, ginger, and garlic?
Tasha: 葱姜蒜超市不送
Tasha: The supermarket doesn’t deliver those.
Jake:啊超市不送
Jake: Ah, the supermarket doesn’t deliver them?
Tasha: 会送吧怎
Tasha: They should, right?
Jake:怎么送啊
Jake: How would they deliver?
Tasha: 要葱姜蒜吗
Tasha: Do you want scallions, ginger, and garlic?
Jake:怎么就就我们买这些东西他就会送葱姜蒜
Jake: How come if we buy these things, they would deliver scallions, ginger, and garlic?
Tasha: 是啊
Tasha: Yeah.
Katrina: 这是干什么的
Katrina: What’s this for?
Tasha: 我只是觉得他会送
Tasha: I just think they would deliver.
Alice:葱怎么卖啊
Alice: How much do scallions cost?
Jake:我我我我我
Jake: I, I, I, I...
Alice:蒜
Alice: Garlic?
Jake:surprise闻所未闻
Jake: Surprise, never heard of it.
Jake:shocked
Jake: Shocked.
Tasha: 真的假的不是
Tasha: Really? No way.
Jake:不不知道
Jake: I don’t know.
Lucia: 你在江苏是不是从来没逛过菜市场
Lucia: Haven’t you ever been to a vegetable market in Jiangsu?
Jake:菜市场逛过这种超市
Jake: I’ve been to vegetable markets like this.
Tasha: 菜市场送不送
Tasha: Do vegetable markets deliver?
Jake: 菜市场可以送
Jake: Vegetable markets can deliver.
Jake: 超市不一定
Jake: Supermarkets, not necessarily.
Alice:买吗
Alice: Should we buy it?
Tasha: 买吧 药 药是吗
Tasha: Let’s buy it. Medicine, right?
Alice:我再想想
Alice: Let me think again.
Alice:需要但是可以不用这么多
Alice: We need it, but not that much.
Alice:但是几个人啊
Alice: But how many people?
Tasha: 我觉得蒜和葱就一个就行了呵呵
Tasha: I think one garlic and one scallion are enough, haha.
Tasha: 这要大葱吗
Tasha: Do we need big scallions?
Tasha: 还是小葱
Tasha: Or small scallions?
Alice: 姜可以不要哎
Alice: We can skip the ginger.
Alice:蒜是出味的
Alice: Garlic gives flavor.
Jake:来让人过
Jake: Let’s get someone over here.
Tasha: 行那那那就要着吧
Tasha: Alright, let’s get it.
Alice:哦不好意思
Alice: Oh, sorry.
Alice:看看加
Alice: Let me check.
Alice:呃在哪呢
Alice: Uh, where is it?
Alice:蒜葱葱也用不了那么多呀
Alice: We don't need that much garlic and green onions.
Tasha: 哎那明天有火锅的话
Tasha: Hey, if we are having hot pot tomorrow...
Tasha: 要不要买火锅底料和肉菜啊
Tasha: Should we buy hot pot base and meat?
Jake:他们买了底料
Jake: They bought the base.
Jake:肉他们好像没买
Jake: But I think they didn't buy meat.
Tasha: 那要不要买肉
Tasha: Should we buy meat?
Jake:可以买肉
Jake: Yeah, we can buy meat.
Jake: 回头对一下
Jake: Let's check later.
Jake: 可以先
Jake: We can first...
Alice:那个您好我们如果买的话会送葱姜蒜
Alice: Hi, if we buy it, will you give us garlic, ginger, and green onions?
Katrina: 为什么呢
Katrina: Why?
Alice:送多少呢大概
Alice: How much will you give approximately?
Alice:就是消费
Alice: Just for spending...
Alice:不会送吗不会送吗
Alice: Won't you give us? Won't you give us?
Tasha: 有的时候会员满9.9会送啊
Tasha: Sometimes members get it for free when they spend 9.9.
Alice:没有没有被送过哎
Alice: No, I've never gotten it for free.
Jake: 啊什么意思啊
Jake: What do you mean?
Jake: 我们还我们还满不了9.9
Jake: We haven't even spent 9.9 yet.
Tasha: 呃主要是我们没有会员啊
Tasha: Uh, mainly because we are not members.
Alice:我好像有会员
Alice: I think I am a member.
Tasha: 你有吗不知道这今天会不会送
Tasha: Are you? Not sure if they'll give it today.
Tasha: 有被送过
Tasha: I have gotten it before.
Alice:有被送过但不一定是吧
Alice: I've gotten it before, but not always.
Tasha: 他好像每天
Tasha: It seems like they do it daily.
Alice:但是这也用不了这么多
Alice: But we don't need that much.
Tasha: 嗯没关系做火锅还要用的
Tasha: Hmm, it's okay, we can use it for the hot pot.
Tasha: 拿着吧
Tasha: Just take it.
Alice:确实拿吧
Alice: Sure, let's take it.
Jake: 好
Jake: Alright.
Alice:你吃板栗仁吗
Alice: Do you eat chestnuts?
Alice: 可以放进去
Alice: We can add them in.
Tasha: 呃都可以
Tasha: Uh, anything is fine.
Alice: 我怕他弄不熟
Alice: I'm afraid they might not cook through.
Tasha: 那算了吧
Tasha: Then forget it.
Alice:因为这个比较难煮
Alice: Because it's hard to cook them.
Jake:哎呀撞着了
Jake: Oops, bumped into it.
Lucia: 哎刚好碰到你们
Lucia: Oh, just ran into you guys.
Katrina:  买完了
Katrina: Done shopping.
Jake:你们
Jake: You guys...
Katrina:  有两个没有
Katrina: There are two missing.
Katrina:  没有有两
Katrina: We don't have two.
Alice:调料
Alice: Seasonings.
Jake: 买肉了吗
Jake: Did you buy the meat?
Jake:火锅什么的他们要
Jake: They want hot pot stuff.
Katrina:  那去去买火锅的食材是吧
Katrina: So, we're buying hot pot ingredients, right?
Jake:那你们去吧
Jake: Yeah, you guys go.
Alice:我们买葱蒜了
Alice: We bought green onions and garlic.
Katrina:  啊葱蒜
Katrina: Ah, green onions and garlic.
Katrina:  那我们去买火锅食材
Katrina: Then we'll go buy hot pot ingredients.
Jake:肉在那去吧
Jake: The meat is over there, go ahead.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure:  烤肉的也要买一下
Shure: We also need to buy barbecue stuff.
Tasha: 那我们的进度好慢啊他们都买完了
Tasha: We're so slow, they've already finished shopping.
Jake:烤肉
Jake: Barbecue.
Jake:嗯对
Jake: Yes, right.
Shure:  等下次好呃
Shure: Next time, uh...
Shure:  先买火锅的食材
Shure: Let's buy the hot pot ingredients first.
Jake: 先火锅吧
Jake: Hot pot first.
Jake: 烤肉是要过一阵的
Jake: Barbecue can wait.
Jake:你你没炭呢还
Jake: You don't have charcoal yet.
Jake: 他们还在买火锅
Jake: They're still buying hot pot stuff.
Shure:  这些都美团都可以送
Shure: Everything can be delivered by Meituan.
Jake:一起嘛
Jake: Together.
Lucia: 放两天应该没事了
Lucia: It should be fine for a couple of days.
Lucia: 但如果我们烧烤是最后一天烤的话
Lucia: But if we barbecue on the last day...
Jake:那都美团送的
Jake: Everything can be delivered by Meituan.
Shure:  但是肉的话可以先买
Shure: But we can buy the meat first.
Jake:肉
Jake: Meat.
Jake:放得下不小冰箱
Jake: Can it fit in the small fridge?
Katrina: 就买买火锅的食材
Katrina: Just buy the hot pot ingredients.
Shure:  在这呢火锅的肉
Shure: Here's the hot pot meat.
Jake:对对万对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, that's right.
Alice: 这已经到熟食区了
Alice: We're already in the deli section.
Alice:盐
Alice: Salt.
Tasha: 加碘哪 有人不能吃碘吗
Tasha: Iodized, right? Can anyone not eat iodine?
Alice:盐来了
Alice: Salt is here.
Alice:碘
Alice: Iodine.
Alice:没人不能吃碘吧
Alice: No one can't eat iodine, right?
Tasha: 那 那调温量
Tasha: Then, adjust the temperature.
Alice:黑胡椒
Alice: Black pepper.
Alice:辣椒粉
Alice: Chili powder.
Alice:买葱姜蒜还是买葱姜蒜粉呢
Alice: Should we buy green onions, ginger, and garlic or their powders?
Tasha: 诶葱姜蒜粉好像可以啊
Tasha: Hey, the powders might work.
Tasha: 但是算了吧
Tasha: But never mind.
Tasha: 因为那个不是还要也要用
Tasha: Because we still need to use them too.
Alice:糖你买了没
Alice: Did you buy the sugar?
Tasha: 哦对糖在这呢
Tasha: Oh right, the sugar is here.
Lucia: 这个便宜的还是买那个贵的
Lucia: Should we buy the cheap one or the expensive one?
Jake:有啥差别吗这个糖
Jake: Is there any difference in the sugar?
Tasha: 你看这5.9 这5.5
Tasha: Look, this one is 5.9, this one is 5.5.
Tasha: 好吧可是这个很绵这个很粗
Tasha: Okay, but this one is fine and this one is coarse.
Jake: 所以哪个好啊
Jake: So which one is better?
Jake:贵4毛钱
Jake: It's 4 cents more.
Jake: 我觉得这种比较正常
Jake: I think this one is more normal.
Jake:500 这个400克OK
Jake: 500 grams, this one is 400 grams, okay.
Tasha: 算了就这个吧
Tasha: Never mind, let's go with this one.
Jake:就这个吧
Jake: Let's go with this one.
Jake:这个棉
Jake: This one is fine.
Tasha: 糖盐胡椒粉
Tasha: Sugar, salt, pepper.
Alice: 你得买绵白糖
Alice: You need to buy fine sugar.
Tasha: 买了绵白糖
Tasha: I bought fine sugar.
Tasha: 糖盐胡椒粉味精味精是吧
Tasha: Sugar, salt, pepper, MSG, right?
Tasha: 你还要味精这呢
Tasha: You still want MSG, here it is.
Alice: 怎么没有味精呢
Alice: Why is there no MSG?
Tasha: 鸡精
Tasha: Chicken essence.
Tasha: 哦还是买了鸡精是吧没有味精是吧
Tasha: Oh, we bought chicken essence, not MSG, right?
Alice:没有没有味精
Alice: No, no MSG.
Jake:没有味精    好的
Jake: No MSG, okay.
Tasha: 差不多味精和鸡精差不多
Tasha: MSG and chicken essence are similar.
Alice:味精会健康一点
Alice: MSG is a bit healthier.
Tasha: 把鸡精挑
Tasha: Remove the chicken essence.
Alice:鸡精的添加剂多一点
Alice: Chicken essence has more additives.
Jake:哦没关系
Jake: Oh, it's fine.
Jake:活到现在了
Jake: We've lived this long.
Tasha: 金针菇松花蛋娃娃菜都买了
Tasha: We bought enoki mushrooms, preserved eggs, and baby cabbage.
Alice: 我买过一个午餐肉
Alice: I bought a can of luncheon meat.
Alice:但我不知道够不够
Alice: But I'm not sure if it's enough.
Tasha: 草莓买了
Tasha: Got the strawberries.
Tasha: 奶油买了
Tasha: Got the cream.
Tasha: 薄荷保鲜膜
Tasha: Mint and cling film.
Tasha: 蛋挞没买呢
Tasha: Didn't get the egg tarts.
Tasha: 我已经开始渴了
Tasha: I'm already getting thirsty.
Tasha: 听到这个声音
Tasha: Hearing this sound.
Jake: 买一会喝
Jake: Buy some to drink later.
Tasha: 这买什么来着 咖啡豆
Tasha: What did we buy again? Coffee beans.
Jake:喝
Jake: Drink.
Jake:咖啡豆
Jake: Coffee beans.
Tasha: 他不知道
Tasha: He doesn't know.
Tasha: 磨咖啡要吗
Tasha: Do we need to grind the coffee?
Jake:咖啡豆在哪买
Jake: Where do we buy coffee beans?
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: No idea.
Alice: 咖啡豆这不好买吧
Alice: Coffee beans aren't easy to buy, right?
Tasha: 你好这里有咖啡豆卖吗
Tasha: Hi, do you sell coffee beans here?
Alice:奶粉哦奶粉是他们买吧
Alice: Oh, milk powder. They buy it, right?
Alice:奶粉是他们买吗
Alice: Do they buy the milk powder?
Alice:我们是几到几啊
Alice: What time slot are we?
Tasha: 我们是5-11
Tasha: We're from 5-11.
Alice: 那我们没有买奶粉
Alice: Then we didn't buy the milk powder.
Tasha: 没事其实奶粉不重要
Tasha: It's okay, the milk powder isn't important.
Tasha: 我只想一小一小包而已
Tasha: I just wanted a small pack anyway.
Jake:丑蛋糕他们在干嘛
Jake: What are they doing with the ugly cake?
Alice:你在找啥呀
Alice: What are you looking for?
Tasha: 咖啡豆
Tasha: Coffee beans.
Alice: 是蓝胖子吧
Alice: Is it the blue tin?
Tasha: 啊太贵了这一罐没必要
Tasha: Ah, this one is too expensive, not necessary.
Jake:水果麦
Jake: Fruit wheat.
Alice: 哎有咖啡粉
Alice: Hey, there's coffee powder.
Katrina: 这还有一个冷藏过的
Katrina: There's also a refrigerated one.
Katrina: 哈喽你们买那个肉制品
Katrina: Hello, did you guys buy the meat products?
Tasha: 你觉得买哪个好
Tasha: Which one do you think is better to buy?
Katrina:  那个肉制品火锅全部就是我们管是吗
Katrina: Are we in charge of all the hotpot meat products?
Tasha: 5 59
Tasha: 5 59.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina: 那你们买了什么
Katrina: Then what did you buy?
Katrina:  青菜吗哎
Katrina: Vegetables, right?
Tasha: 他要磨咖啡
Tasha: He wants to grind coffee.
Jake:买了买了
Jake: Got it, got it.
Alice:那这种是不是
Alice: So this one is...
Katrina: 好像没有买青菜
Katrina: Seems like we didn't buy any greens.
Tasha: 这是你要的咖啡豆吗
Tasha: Are these the coffee beans you wanted?
Jake:买了不多就买一个
Jake: We bought some, but not much, just one.
Lucia: 还是多啊
Lucia: Still seems like a lot.
Alice: 还是这种的
Alice: Or maybe this kind?
Jake:这个今天是他们要做上汤娃娃菜
Jake: This is for the cabbage soup they're making today.
Jake:专门给他上汤娃娃菜搞的蔬菜
Jake: These vegetables are specifically for his cabbage soup.
Shure:  就是这个有点捞
Shure: This one's a bit too much.
Jake:应该没有别的菜了
Jake: I think that's all the veggies.
Katrina:  也就是说火锅下的菜跟
Katrina: So, the veggies for the hot pot and...
Jake:火锅没有菜
Jake: There's no veggies for the hot pot.
Jake:对火锅还没有菜
Jake: Yeah, no veggies for the hot pot yet.
Katrina: 肉质都是我们挑
Katrina: We chose the meat ourselves.
Katrina:  那我们得多加一点
Katrina: We need to add a bit more.
Katrina:  感觉6个人不够吃哎
Katrina: Feels like it's not enough for six people.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, you're right.
Alice: 你买了吗
Alice: Did you buy it?
Shure: 我买了  啊 对
Shure: I bought it, yes.
Lucia: 你可以先看一下吗
Lucia: Can you check it first?
Tasha:这个吗 那行那我就不不拿了
Tasha: This one? Okay, then I won't take it.
Lucia: 现在买的东西
Lucia: The stuff we bought now...
Jake:好一会我们对一下等他们一起对一下
Jake: Okay, we'll check it later together.
Jake:盘算一下
Jake: Let's calculate it.
Katrina: 还得买两盒肉哎
Katrina: We still need to buy two more boxes of meat.
Jake:他们现在在套好
Jake: They're preparing now.
Lucia: 好奇一下你们这边的东西
Lucia: I'm curious about your stuff here.
Jake:他们在研究咖啡豆
Jake: They're researching coffee beans.
Tasha: 保鲜膜
Tasha: Plastic wrap.
Alice:保鲜膜
Alice: Plastic wrap.
Jake:咖啡豆
Jake: Coffee beans.
Lucia: 我们刚才好像是拿了一盒速溶咖啡
Lucia: Earlier, we seemed to have taken a box of instant coffee.
Shure:  我跟他跟他说了
Shure: I told him about it.
Jake:哦速溶但是这个就慢
Jake: Oh, instant coffee is slower though.
Lucia: 嗯？有泰拉
Lucia: Hmm? There’s Terra.
Katrina: 什么呀
Katrina: What?
Shure:  咖啡豆的话
Shure: As for coffee beans...
Lucia: 就是这个
Lucia: It's this one.
Lucia: 好久不见了 从我回国
Lucia: Long time no see since I returned home.
Katrina:  你们拿椰奶了吗
Katrina: Did you get the coconut milk?
Alice:有椰子水
Alice: There's coconut water.
Shure:  购入一下
Shure: Let's buy some.
Lucia: mitchposticks怎么还是从德国进口了
Lucia: Why are the mitchposticks still imported from Germany?
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Katrina:  我们拿椰子汁了吗
Katrina: Did we get the coconut juice?
Alice: 你们需要吗
Alice: Do you guys need it?
Katrina:  我在想
Katrina: I'm thinking.
Katrina:  咖啡是不是可以兑一点椰子汁啊
Katrina: Can we mix a bit of coconut juice with coffee?
Katrina:  生椰拿铁
Katrina: Like a coconut latte.
Alice:椰奶吗
Alice: Coconut milk?
Katrina:  嗯但是那种大的咖啡
Katrina: Yeah, but for a large coffee.
Shure: 可以
Shure: Sure.
Katrina:  呃椰奶是不是只能放一天
Katrina: Uh, can coconut milk only last a day?
Alice:不开封的话可以放几天
Alice: If it's unopened, it can last a few days.
Katrina:  那就是开了那就得一天喝完呗
Katrina: So if we open it, we have to finish it in a day?
Katrina:  我没看他那种小盒的椰树你知道吗
Katrina: I didn't see those small boxes of coconut milk, you know?
Katrina:  他都是大盒的椰树
Katrina: They only have large boxes.
Jake:螺蛳粉看到了
Jake: I saw the snail noodles.
Lucia: 那个
Lucia: That one.
Jake:真的
Jake: Really.
Katrina:  你去问一下子吧你拿
Katrina: You should go ask, and take it.
Jake:我们要对一下吗
Jake: Should we match it?
Lucia: 感觉可以
Lucia: Sounds good.
Jake: 好那
Jake: Alright then.
Alice:其实那个大的你开封之后放两三天
Alice: Actually, after you open the large one, it can last two or three days.
Jake:那找个地方
Jake: Let's find a place.
Jake: 我们先对一下吧
Jake: Let's match it first.
Lucia: 对保鲜膜可以在超市买
Lucia: You can buy cling film at the supermarket.
Jake:对一下我们找一个
Jake: Let's match it first and find one.
Alice:我一般买这种大的
Alice: I usually buy the large ones.
Tasha: 买咖啡液也行 就不用咖啡粉就不用速溶咖啡调了
Tasha: You can buy coffee concentrate, so you don't need to use coffee powder or instant coffee.
Alice:之后放两三天也没事
Alice: After that, it can last two or three days.
Alice: 不用他那个变质的话会很明显
Alice: If it spoils, it'll be very obvious.
Katrina: 要么直接叫外卖吧
Katrina: Or we could just order takeout.
Shure:  也行反正都都都行
Shure: That works too, anything's fine.
Jake:都行反正我也不喝咖啡
Jake: Anything's fine, I don't drink coffee anyway.
Shure: 那你今天
Shure: Then today...
Jake:哈哈早上不行啊
Jake: Haha, not in the morning.
Katrina: 不知道以为我们工作呢
Katrina: People might think we're working.
Jake:早上喝了一下
Jake: I had a bit in the morning.
Shure: 不行了是吧
Jake:不行那要喝一下
Lucia: 其实还好
Shure:  我靠哥
Jake:这两天应该就行了
Jake:昨天也搞定了
Shure: 还行吧现在
Jake:昨天拍破蛋搞定了
Alice:肉在哪啊
Jake:下面就是
Jake:执行就行
Tasha: 再买点丸子和虾滑
Shure: 你身体还说得过去吗
Katrina:  丸子买了虾滑也买了
Jake:强的很
Katrina:  虾滑在这哦
Shure: 真的吗 多久没体检了
Katrina:  我觉得还要拿两盒肉
Katrina:  青菜也没买哎
Lucia: 我们为什么买哦
Lucia: 哦哦蔬菜是吧
Lucia: Oh, oh, vegetables, right?
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Lucia: 蔬菜哦新到的咸鱼土豆
Lucia: Vegetables, oh, and the new salted fish potatoes.
Katrina:  你要吃土豆是吗
Katrina: You want to eat potatoes, right?
Shure:  土豆好土豆可以
Shure: Potatoes are good, potatoes are fine.
Jake:土豆可以啊
Jake: Potatoes are fine.
Lucia: 其实我也喜欢
Lucia: Actually, I like them too.
Katrina: 走吧那我们蔬菜买肉跟青菜
Katrina: Let's go then, we'll buy vegetables, meat, and greens.
Jake:咱不是还有那个削土豆皮的那个
Jake: Don't we still have that potato peeler thing?
Tasha: 那个不是完了小土豆皮奥
Tasha: Isn't that for small potato skins?
Tasha: 芋头没有买
Tasha: We didn't buy taro.
Jake:走
Jake: Let's go.
Shure: 芋头是啥啊
Shure: What's taro?
Lucia: 芋头放火锅吗
Lucia: Do you put taro in hotpot?
Alice:芋头
Alice: Taro.
Tasha: 不是芋泥
Tasha: Not taro paste.
Lucia: 啊okok
Lucia: Ah, okay, okay.
Shure: 芋泥
Shure: Taro paste.
Jake:哎呀这什么东西
Jake: Oh man, what is this?
Lucia: sorry没有跟上这个频道
Lucia: Sorry, I couldn't keep up with the channel.
Shure: 芋泥
Shure: Taro mash
Katrina: 芋泥芋泥耶
Katrina: Taro mash, yay
Alice:芋头放火锅也很好吃
Alice: Taro is also great in hotpot.
Alice: 那个荔浦芋头
Alice: That Lipu taro.
Jake:酱香烤鸭
Jake: Saucy roast duck.
Tasha: 对我是要买荔浦芋头
Tasha: Yeah, I need to buy Lipu taro.
Tasha: 走吧诶不对
Tasha: Let's go, oh wait.
Shure: 芋芋泥能波波吗
Shure: Can taro mash make bubbles?
Tasha: 好那我们的爆皮刀就有两用了
Tasha: Great, then our peeler has two uses.
Jake:哈哈哈走
Jake: Hahaha, let's go.
Katrina: 哈哈少来这种
Katrina: Haha, stop with that.
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh no.
Alice:咋了
Alice: What happened?
Tasha: 你喜欢吃吗
Tasha: Do you like it?
Jake: 吃什么呀
Jake: Like what?
Tasha: 这个
Tasha: This.
Jake: 螺蛳粉啊
Jake: Snail noodles?
Jake:嗯呃能吃就没
Jake: Hmm, well, I can eat it.
Jake: 那么没一定要吃
Jake: But I don't really have to.
Jake: 对没那么想吃
Jake: Not really craving it.
Jake:doyouknow
Jake: Do you know?
Jake:就是就是
Jake: I mean, I mean,
Jake:没得吃可以吃一吃
Jake: If there's nothing else, I can eat it.
Tasha: 谁去买蔬菜他们去买蔬菜
Tasha: Who's buying veggies? Are they?
Alice:我们啊
Alice: We are.
Jake:他们他们买蔬菜
Jake: They're buying veggies.
Jake:他们买蔬菜
Alice:我们菜不是在那边吗
Alice: Aren't the veggies over there?
Jake:我我对啊你们他们
Jake: I, I, yeah, you, they are.
Tasha: 他们可能先买肉吧
Tasha: Maybe they're buying meat first.
Jake: 他们买帝王蟹是吧
Jake: They're buying king crab, right?
Tasha: 这个也在资金范围内吗
Tasha: Is that within the budget?
Jake:你们买海鲜
Jake: You guys buy seafood.
Jake:哈哈不不你们买海鲜吗
Jake: Haha, no, no, are you buying seafood?
Lucia: 哇哦 我可以吃这个吗
Lucia: Wow, can I eat this?
Jake: 哈哈哈打打招呼吧
Jake: Hahaha, say hi.
Jake: 要不就拍一拍吧要不
Jake: Or just wave.
Jake: 你好
Jake: Hello.
Lucia: 扫描一下
Lucia: Scan it.
Jake: 1,699也还行吧
Jake: 1,699 is okay, right?
Tasha: 那来一只吧
Tasha: Then let's have one.
Lucia: 真的吗可以吃吗
Lucia: Really? Can we eat it?
Lucia: 哈哈哈来一只吧
Lucia: Hahaha, let's have one.
Shure:  你千万不要口嗨
Shure: Don't just talk big.
Shure:  我们会当真的好不好
Shure: We'll take it seriously, alright?
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Jake:我就说也还行
Jake: I just said it's okay.
Jake:我没多说什么
Jake: I didn't say much.
Tasha: 有没有那个转架还是干嘛
Tasha: Do we have that rotator thing or what?
Jake:哈哈哈我没哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha, I didn't hahaha.
Lucia: 也还行我们就把这个野字去掉吧啊
Lucia: It's okay, let's just remove the word "wild", alright?
Lucia: 把还字也去掉
Lucia: And remove the word "okay".
Shure: 蘸料你们买了吗
Shure: Did you buy the dipping sauce?
Jake:行
Jake: Sure.
Lucia: 对对对我们自动识别成型
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, we automatically recognize and form it.
Jake:好好
Jake: Alright, alright.
Shure:  蘸料你们买了吗
Shure: Did you buy the dipping sauce?
Alice:蘸料没有
Alice: No dipping sauce.
Lucia: 没有买蘸料
Lucia: Didn't buy dipping sauce.
Shure:  你们都吃什么碟的火锅一般
Shure: What kind of dipping sauce do you usually have with hot pot?
Alice:麻酱
Alice: Sesame sauce.
Shure: 麻酱醋麻酱
Shure: Sesame sauce, vinegar, sesame sauce.
Tasha: 我要醋
Tasha: I want vinegar.
Lucia: 芝麻酱
Lucia: Sesame sauce.
Tasha: 你吃什么碟呢 醋碟
Tasha: What kind of dipping sauce do you use? Vinegar?
Shure:  你吃火锅一般吃什么蘸料
Shure: What dipping sauce do you usually have with hot pot?
Alice:麻酱
Alice: Sesame sauce.
Jake:呃麻酱吧
Jake: Uh, sesame sauce.
Alice: 油碟
Alice: Oil sauce.
Jake:你吃什么碟
Jake: What sauce do you use?
Tasha: 你背叛了江苏人
Tasha: You betrayed the people of Jiangsu.
Lucia: 那我们现在醋和麻酱还有什么别的需要吗
Lucia: So we have vinegar and sesame sauce, do we need anything else?
Jake:其实我在江苏都没怎么吃过火锅
Jake: Actually, I hardly ever had hot pot in Jiangsu.
Jake:我都是上了大学才
Jake: I only started in college.
Jake:你是醋碟吗
Jake: You use vinegar sauce?
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yeah.
Tasha: 我们不应该都和喝恒硕香醋长大的吗
Tasha: Weren't we all supposed to grow up drinking Hengshuo vinegar?
Shure:  杨老板吃什么
Shure: What does Jake use?
Jake:呃就麻将吧
Jake: Uh, just sesame sauce.
Jake:或者当回江苏人吧
Jake: Or I'll be a Jiangsu person again.
Jake:要不吃醋碟也行
Jake: How about having vinegar sauce instead?
Tasha: 对啊醋碟
Tasha: Yeah, vinegar sauce.
Alice:这是熟食了
Alice: This is cooked food.
Tasha: 对应该在那吧
Tasha: Yeah, it should be over there.
Lucia: 也可以其实火锅还挺省钱的
Lucia: Actually, hot pot can be quite economical.
Lucia: 嗯只要一堆食材往里一煮就好了哈
Lucia: Yeah, just throw a bunch of ingredients in and cook them.
Jake: 对是的粽子也很省钱哈哈哈哈
Jake: Yeah, right. Zongzi is also very economical, hahaha.
Jake: 买点方便面吧
Jake: How about buying some instant noodles?
Jake: 算了算了哈哈哈
Jake: Never mind, never mind, hahaha.
Katrina:  后面两天经费不足
Katrina: We're short on budget for the next two days.
Katrina:  天天方便面
Katrina: Instant noodles every day.
Tasha: 你觉得芋头会在哪有呢
Tasha: Where do you think we can find taro?
Katrina: 找到醋了吗
Katrina: Did you find the vinegar?
Jake:干啥去啦
Jake: Where did you go?
Shure: 没找到反正
Shure: Couldn't find it anyway.
Shure:  你好调料的那些在哪里
Shure: Excuse me, where are the condiments?
Alice: 这种是不是也可以涮火锅
Alice: Can this also be used for hot pot?
Alice:这种魔芋之类的
Alice: This kind of konjac or something.
Tasha: 但是他们会不会买豆制品呢
Tasha: But would they buy tofu products?
Alice: 不知道那
Alice: I don't know.
Tasha: 那那那我觉得要来一个豆腐
Tasha: Well, well, well, I think we need some tofu.
Jake:豆腐
Jake: Tofu.
Jake:包浆豆腐
Jake: Wrapped tofu.
Alice: 我需要魔芋
Alice: I need konjac.
Tasha: 你喜欢吃这种干豆腐还是吃
Tasha: Do you prefer dried tofu or...
Alice:内酯豆腐
Alice: Lactone tofu.
Tasha: 内酯豆腐
Tasha: Lactone tofu.
Tasha: 这个呢浆水豆腐哎
Tasha: How about this one, water tofu?
Jake:这都什么差别
Jake: What's the difference between these?
Jake: 这个这个一般
Jake: This one is just so-so.
Jake:我感觉这个有点硬
Jake: I feel this one is a bit hard.
Alice:就是那种老豆腐
Alice: It's just old tofu.
Tasha: 那就这种吧
Tasha: Then let's go with this one.
Jake:啊可以
Jake: Ah, okay.
Jake:看起来不错
Jake: Looks good.
Tasha: 鲜豆腐 豆腐皮呢
Tasha: Fresh tofu. What about tofu skin?
Alice:魔芋你要吃那种
Alice: Do you want to eat that konjac?
Tasha: 魔芋
Tasha: Konjac.
Alice:对
Alice: Right.
Tasha: 这个魔芋好奇怪
Tasha: This konjac looks weird.
Alice:这魔芋就是这种的
Alice: This konjac is like this.
Tasha: 有没有魔芋丝
Tasha: Is there konjac noodles?
Alice:魔芋丝
Alice: Konjac noodles.
Tasha: 魔芋丝魔芋丝或者魔芋皮都行
Tasha: Konjac noodles or konjac skin, both are fine.
Alice:这种比较原生
Alice: This one is more natural.
Tasha: 行那再拿个这个吧
Tasha: Okay, then let's take this one.
Alice:3块9可以
Alice: 3.9 yuan is okay.
Alice: 买这个金针菇吧这个便宜
Alice: Let's buy these enoki mushrooms, they're cheaper.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Alice:: 呃把这个有机的给它放回去
Alice: Uh, put the organic one back.
Jake: 对咱就不要那么有机了
Jake: Yeah, let's not be so organic.
Alice: 这有娃娃菜吗
Alice: Do they have baby bok choy here?
Alice: 让我找找
Alice: Let me look for it.
Jake:哎你问的好
Jake: Oh, good question.
Jake:跟丢了
Jake: Lost track.
Katrina: 感觉他的脑袋一口
Katrina: Feels like his head got bitten off.
Shure:  完了跟丢了去搜寻吧
Shure: We lost them, let's search.
Jake:找你们去了
Jake: Came to find you all.
Tasha: 烤地瓜吗
Tasha: Roasted sweet potato?
Jake:烤就放烤箱
Jake: If roasting, put it in the oven.
Alice: 放吧另一个呢
Alice: Put it in, where's the other one?
Tasha: 另什么另一个
Tasha: The other what?
Jake:放烤箱是吧
Jake: Put it in the oven, right?
Tasha: 噢噢烟薯是吗
Tasha: Oh, oh, the smoky sweet potato?
Jake:土豆
Jake: Potato.
Tasha: 好吧我想吃
Tasha: Okay, I want to eat it.
Jake: 有土豆吗
Jake: Do we have potatoes?
Jake: 我不用我不用
Jake: I don't need it, I don't need it.
Jake:我乱说的
Jake: I was just talking nonsense.
Jake:因为刚刚不是提到了吗
Jake: Because it was mentioned earlier.
Alice:两个
Alice: Two.
Jake:给你加俩土豆
Jake: I'll add two potatoes for you.
Jake:耶
Jake: Yay.
Tasha: 你只要爱吃土豆对你就可以加入
Tasha: As long as you love eating potatoes, you can join.
Tasha: 申请加入我们土门
Tasha: Apply to join our potato clan.
Jake:你是土豆
Jake: You're a potato.
Tasha: 呃只需要交298元一年
Tasha: Uh, you just need to pay 298 yuan a year.
Jake:为啥这是什么门
Jake: Why, what kind of door is this?
Katrina: 叫什么金针菇那种
Katrina: It's called golden needle mushroom or something.
Alice:会员费
Alice: Membership fee.
Jake:每天都可以吃土豆吗
Jake: Can you eat potatoes every day?
Jake:呃有什么
Jake: Uh, what's there?
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Tasha: 只要看见我就可以吃
Tasha: As long as you see me, you can eat.
Jake:土豆夹子哦
Jake: Potato clip, huh?
Tasha: 你跟他们说我们买了土豆
Tasha: Tell them we bought potatoes.
Tasha: 还有豆制品豆腐什么
Tasha: And soybean products, tofu, etc.
Tasha: 豆腐的都买了
Tasha: We bought all the tofu.
Katrina: 那我们把豆制品要放了吗
Katrina: So, should we put the soybean products away?
Alice: 买了魔芋
Alice: We bought konjac.
Lucia: 我们也买了豆腐好像
Lucia: We also bought tofu, I think.
Alice:买了什么豆腐
Alice: What kind of tofu did we buy?
Shure:  豆腐什么
Shure: What tofu?
Shure:  4拼这种豆制品拼盘
Shure: A platter with four kinds of soybean products.
Alice:哦不一样的东西
Alice: Oh, different things.
Katrina: 你这个你这个是做什么的啊
Katrina: What is this for?
Tasha: 你这个是干的
Tasha: This one is dried.
Tasha: 这是鲜的啊
Tasha: This one is fresh.
Katrina: 就是放火锅里吃吗
Katrina: Do we eat this in hot pot?
Tasha: 鲜豆腐
Tasha: Fresh tofu.